Hello, everyone. Ashley here presenting to you the importance of exercise and the cancer
relation. The most important thing our exercise helps our body do is detox. We want to get
to the point of sweating but not muscle soreness. Any muscle soreness will then create
lactic acid and that is what we want to prevent. Sweating helps us release the toxins from
our body. This then will improve the function of the organs to be able to detox and filter
the toxins out. This also improves your immunity. Benefits of exercise is that it helps make your
bones dense which means fewer fractures. It keeps or improves your physical abilities especially
for your daily life. It prevents muscles from being wasted due to inactivity. It improves blood
flow which then lowers the risk of blood clots and it also helps lessen nausea. This diagram
explains how exercise helps during cancer treatments. A few things listed on here is that it helps
reduce chemo brain, improves efficiency of treatment, improves tolerance of treatment, improves immune
function, reduces recurrence, increases chance of survival and improves your quality of life.
Some other benefits of exercise specifically with bone and muscle health is that it helps reduce
the risk of osteoporosis. It stimulates the growth of tiny blood vessels in your muscle tissues.
A robotic exercise specifically can help lessen pain. The oxygen supply to the muscle is improved
and waste products are removed more efficiently. It can also improve the bone and muscle health
to help with balance and prevent falls and breaking the bones. The cardiovascular side of this
is that it improves your cardiovascular fitness. It increases your capacity to use oxygen.
It increases your heart's capacity to send blood and oxygen to the muscles. This then creates
an oxygenated environment which cancers do not like to live in. It is very hard for them to survive
so make sure that your body stays alkalized. A wide exercise. Exercise can actually change the tumor
environment and influence the effectiveness of treatment with radiation and chemotherapy.
The tumor environment contains areas of low oxygen, term tapoxia, which make them resistant to
radiotherapy and more likely to metastasize. Exercise appears to combat this issue. It increases the
amount of blood flow to the tumor resulting in better oxygenation of the tumor. A study found that
low to moderate exercise increased blood flow to the tumors by 200 percent and decreased tumor
hypoxia by 50 percent. They saw that during exercise there was a greater reduction in hypoxia
up to 90 percent after training. Versus what only occurs with other conventional treatments for
tumor hypoxia. So what can happen during treatments is called coquexia. What is coquexia? It is weakness
and wasting of the body due to severe chronic illness. How do we prevent it by exercising?
What happens is patients go through pharmaceutical protocol and stop exercising or never had begun
in the first place. When you stop exercising you lose your muscle mass. When you lose your muscle mass
symptoms like anorexia and fatigue can occur. Intumor associated coquexia, few studies address the
potential of exercise as a therapy. In cancer treatments efforts are generally restricted to
pharmaceutical treatments aiming at tumor growth control. Yet little attention is given to the
systemic effects of cancer. The pharmaceutical therapy may aggravate coquexia, contributing to anorexia,
fatigue, skeletal muscle depletion and inflammation. Exercise may counteract both tumor and treatment
derived systemic effects. Studies have shown that endurance and strength training are both
beneficial with treatments in gaining strength, decreasing systemic inflammation and preventing muscle
mass loss. This diagram here is informational as far as showing the positive effects of exercise
with coquexia. So exercise can actually help improve the resting energy expenditure,
improve the oxygen consumption and improve the bone mineral density. It can combat the negatives
that are up here without exercise. So which exercise approach is best? How about both? Cardio and
strength both have their own benefits. Cardio has the improved heart conditions and they are typically
body weight exercises. Strength is more muscle mass and strength building and that's typically a weight
bearing exercise. They both have similar benefits as well, which are the oxygen environment for the
cells, increased blood flow and red blood cells, improve your lymphatic system. So combining both of
those together or even doing them separately you will still be benefiting your body. The goal is not
soreness. We just want to concentrate on contracting the muscles because that's what's going to
increase the blood flow and the lymph movement. We want to strengthen your muscles, not make them sore.
Do more than you did the previous week and let yourself adapt each week, then do a little more.
It is a great way to track your progress. Remember your body aspires to move. If you don't use it,
you lose it. Don't take the ability to move for granted. Someone always has it worse, so be
thankful. Exercise is just a piece of your healing puzzle and it is meant to strengthen your muscles,
build your immune system and be proud of your progress no matter what. I hope this information helps
you on your journey. Thank you.